in a park in central kiev military
drills teaching the basics of combat to
civilians from all walks of life
this is how young people like arsene
a student in the science of plants spend
their weekend
come
came naturally
i just have to protect my family
of course i hope that this situation
would escalate and i can
continue my scientific work and not be
affected by war
it's all part of a program to become
member of the territorial defense units
they are run by regular military
officers or combat veterans like igor
rajyanov who first served in the then
soviet army
i don't feel comfortable fighting the
russians we're all slavic but we're on
our own land and we have to defend it we
understand the situation it's not nice
to kill someone but sometimes we have to
i feel responsible for these young
people
similar drills are happening all over
ukraine
the government is hoping to form up to
25 brigades to be deployed in cities
around the country
last year parliament passed a law that
allows ordinary citizens to join these
territorial defense units now they are
part of the country's strategic defense
plan and their role is to provide
popular resistance
in case the ukrainian army is
these units are now part of the military
alongside the navy air force and army
32 percent of ukrainians say they are
willing to enlist
they won't carry heavy weaponry that is
left to the regular army it's now better
equipped
as military support pours in from
several western countries
but for martha uskiv the role of these
popular resistance units is crucial even
though she can find herself in harm's
way our main task is to support army not
in the front line but on the back
and also to
protect infrastructure to support
civilians i'm afraid that nobody knows
what's going to happen but it's better
to be prepared actually because it could
change any time and nowadays it changes
very quickly
u.s and russian diplomats haven't made
any progress yet
the uncertainty has gone up a notch and
with it the urgency among ukrainians to
mobilize sooner rather than later
al jazeera kiev